I got my friend out of a major Jam
because he was about to move in with his
girlfriend and I neutral friend of ours
you've met him oh oh oh yeah and he was
bad move his girlfriend but he had a
Colombian girlfriend on side that's at
peace and I called him I said hey hey
Bubba looking for you he might be out
with your Colombian girl but whatever
and she heard the message oh yeah hey
girls hey way to go I'm a dead man and I
got to find a way out of this and so I
go okay call me up call me up and ask me
what I meant is this refluent
now this is is too old for this weekend
now we were younger but it was it was
listen you know these are situations
where you're about to move in with your
girl your house is on fire
slow down drop the ball I [ __ ] I
[ __ ] I grenaded did I drop a little
grenade like you guys didn't move in
halfway around her
here you go mind if I pull the pin and
just drive you guys have a good time
good god I mean she's losing her [ __ ]
so she's by the way at the time in
Austin she was on a business trip cause
up he goes hey I go hey [ __ ] uh you
mentioned something about my Colombian
girl I go what he goes my Colombian girl
I go I did and he goes yeah what were
you talking about I go I don't know I
don't know if I mentioned we had the
dinner you didn't I go and I go oh [ __ ]
you mean Nina the neckroll Nina the
neckroll Nina then that crawl he goes
where I go
why were you talking that girl she had
net mean to me were talking you were
talking to her that Colombian girl that
giant Colombian girl you were talking to
her all [ __ ] night and we were looking
at her neck rolls I've never seen
anything like and I went to a whole a
whole detailed story about Nina and her
neck rolls and he's good and he and and
it got him out of the [ __ ] mix I just
I just had to keep it that girl remind
you of that long story a little long
story but I got him out of it he called
me because you're a genius I'm good
go well you might want to you know just
crazy with and then that Colombian girl
turned out to be she was a hooker I
didn't know well she was longer than oh
but but but then she stopped she cut
Luke's leaves she lure men where he was
paying her and she goes you'd have to
pay me anymore but she wanted yeah Daddy
Warbucks yeah and then he decided he had
to break up with her and then she
threatened to have her hurt narcho
boyfriend rise come out kill him like
yeah so there was that it was really
good it's good stuff no more no crows
and then he was killed your friend died
and he died he was pulled apart would be
nice with motorcycle do you get a lot of
hate walk cuz you know I say some
country stuff for you oh yeah what some
stuff I always tell people my I think
it's like my my like my iTunes you know
third album and they put that iTunes
review average it's oh it's almost
always two and a half stars
two and a half because it's you and it
is it's every review is five stars or
once yeah yeah or maybe it's three I
guess that would be laters I'd like it's
literally like the greatest of all time
followed by this man needs to have wash
his mouth out with soap and talk to his
mama yeah all my greatest artists of all
ever who lived followed by you know five
like what's wrong like he needs mental
help you know it's just how it goes
there's nothing I that's what I love I
don't want you know I'll be in the
middle I don't want be mind this is you
know I want you know there's a guy
that's saying it's stand up to you like
if you're pissing off twenty percent of
the audience you're doing your job is
enough yeah you know I mean that's
really what no seize up and and you know
that's what my problem with country
music nowadays is there's nothing that
they put out there that could there they
don't want to piss anybody off it's just
their plane is so [ __ ] safe you know
how do they always though hasn't country
music always well that's I mean that's
why those guys are my heroes is like
back in the 70s it got really like poppy
to is just the technology was never they
put a lot of orchestration on it became
very sappy and then Waylon came in and
Willie were just like [ __ ] this up where
they actually went the left national
went back to Texas
stripped down the band just could tell
they go [ __ ] this guitar bass pedal
steel we're gonna record live you know
just with the band but that was like
seem to always be about I don't know
enough about it but it did always seem
to be pretty literal and the metaphors
were like you know was about the girl
about the guy about being a
American and you always had to be
careful with the Dixie Chicks when they
came out against the president there
there that audience turned on them oh
they know oh so we like nothing they
shot him to Mars literally career over
from all that hard work they went up on
the stand so good - and it was you know
it was like that makes what that happen
- that makes Kevin Spacey almost look
like nothing I guess so is that what it
had they ever bounce back no well they
just did they said it's a world tour the
first one that I think since then that I
think was it touring is different
because you know just fainted yeah I
think the tour the tour went pretty well
I don't know somebody's in mind but do
people just stop buying their albums is
that what happens well at the time when
they did what happened was yeah it was
um it wasn't he people were actually
were calling up the stations and going
if you play this way and listen to your
station anymore so the station's didn't
really plan it they were just like head
of have meat like what the marketplace
spoke yeah it was it was I mean and I'm
pissed at the station's in some ways but
also what do you do if everyone says
worrying listen to your stay you don't
play why didn't they got up their engine
just the main one say something those
are all of my friends one time and we
were it was like fourth of July we were
we're at a fountain in DC and we're my
buddy just looked at us and he goes hey
Bros writing is we've been looking at
this house staring at the [ __ ] found
that they will fans be able to see the
video parts of it I did I did mushrooms
I thought I never liked it we went back
to my our house and we played that was
that old NBA basketball NBA gym NBA Jam
and we did both decide that like like
why is this game have to be like
competition man we should just go hang
out with the fans and we both want we
you know it stops the game on the ball
at times we both we were both like one
to go I we were both so out of it we
wanted to go talk and hang out with the
fans be more loving I was like why
painting competitions about meat so we
just kept trying to walk into the stands
like it was a [ __ ] you I'm smoke or
drink before your concerts no I've weed
before a show is horrible with lyrics as
possible and I'll have a couple drinks
sometimes but I've actually been
recently
which is with us with the you know the
road is tough
speaking of journey you know it's just
there's no way to kind of recover see
there's no recovery day is like the next
night is Kansas City then Oklahoma City
so I'm flying are you on tour bus or on
a bus yeah I mean it's like no you can't
do you can't do it yeah I'll try I'll
have a couple drinks maybe but are you
uh do you have you ever done mushrooms
no never huh
there are trippy mane mushrooms change
your life geez my life people say about
DMT too and stuff I don't think I don't
think there's a drug I'm gonna quit that
will ever change my life mushrooms that
maybe I was a young man but goddamn
maybe it's when you're younger in our
shower and I came out a new job a new
person you know people say DMT like
you'll never look at the world to save
yeah that's good student when I stand
alone - [ __ ] yes I'm like you a little
bit two inches like any face time
someone's told me this is gonna change
your life I'm like I don't know man it
never does yeah what does that mean
change your life I mean what's your
opinion on immediate rematches Aldo is
getting one that's just a matter of
circumstance but after UFC 252 17 a lot
of people were talking about JJ and Cody
and whatnot what's your stance JJ yes
because of her legacy Cody no because he
didn't defend the belt so if you have a
long history of defending the belt in
your multi time world champion immediate
title defenses make sense just like they
do in boxing but if you were kind of
beat the champ and then you get the belt
and then you lose you're not get you got
to kind of work your way back up the
ladder to depend on the division but
especially in that division bantamweight
especially looking at what TJ had to go
through so it all depends on your legacy
and where you're at in your career and
your fame level what do you think about
rose kind of brushing off the immediate
rematch she can do that it you don't
have enough power or frame or control to
really have a say in it mhm
I would be willing to batch fight you on
an ex okay I mean you want to deserves
it after she deserves it the other
matchups there's I was like n there's
not they're not great for rows with the
matchups and you know you
do you know Thanksgivings next week I
know I just found out like recently I
don't give a [ __ ] about thanks giving
Wow why I could give two [ __ ]
hey I don't like Turkey it's a dry ass
bird I think you should have pizzas or
calzones the other it's just I don't
care about it man I do not know about
Thanksgiving and it's [ __ ] up might be
anti-american I don't know I I'm not a
Thanksgiving guy
the food's all right stuff I like
stuffing like cranberry sauce stuffing
is the best I like pumpkin pie pecan pie
with my skip coffee
I've never had P comp oh my god it's not
dad seriously if it's done well it's the
best all the night think about I think
the secret is to always stay connected
with your kids whether if you can't see
them as much at least call that what
phones yeah that's the right time yeah I
always continue to tell your children
yeah I mean remember you know so even if
they don't see they know daddy still
love me yeah you know I mean I mean did
you grow up with that with with with
parents so I like like that and they
love us you know my friend wasn't like
that you know me we didn't grow up in a
family where they said you know not
constantly you know yeah I remember
probably two times my father said you
loved him one time he was looking at me
yeah you know me you know you know I
would because I love you yeah that's
what I chose to burn to when I would my
son so you know I mean but the thing
about it though
although my family didn't tell me that
you know but they showed me in other
ways
yeah I'm saying especially my father
because even with my mother
even with my mother step out of the
picture for a while my father was there
you know care of all of us some time he
went how many where was four of us at
that time you know me and four
especially for a man yeah so he did
everything you know so that must I had
to respect them for that you know I
don't we're not yeah that's what made me
a strong man and being able I'm a
provider yes you know I'm saying I might
not beat her all the time physically but
mentally and spiritually you know I'm
always there I mean in your name just
for my kids not even just for my family
but other families as well - I do a lot
of stuff with people I just don't
promote it out there because I do it
from the heart
yeah I'm saying I don't need publicity
out there oh wow I don't need that I
feel like you'd be doing it anyways if
you're a world champion or not almost
I've been always been known to be a
provider you know I mean always and
because I'm a great type of guy that can
save my money into and I put it in the
right areas as well - but even even
before money there's little things that
I had you know I still was able to give
people something that that was not
fortunate to have we're sure much as I
had you know I think these are the time
were God is smiling down on me yeah and
blessed me so much because boxing is
just a platform that he put me on I
think at the end of my life when it's
all said and done it's gonna be way
beyond boxing you know I mean this is
just a stage to gather the people for
sure decision a message and then after
that man out you know I think you got
some big in store for me
you